good morning John how you doing that
thank you
[Applause]
hi we're in Canton Ohio question Tuesday
the day that Hank answers real questions
from real nerdfighters let's get right
to it did you get some questions for me
I did thanks for making my video easier
I'm a little stressed out song you
thought on repeat recently what was it
don't stop
no just besito God we have listened to a
lot of death besito in the last 48 hours
I didn't put that's Percy to in the book
that's why there's a sequel what's the
best kind of cheese American of course
that's factually incorrect it's a flop
it's got a cricket cricket no you can't
choose a favorite cheese that's
ridiculous there are different types of
cheeses for different moods and I like
goat I like goats what's your favorite
type of go feel like that would be
really mean to pick a favorite go like
all those other goats do you mean like
all our goat fans will who watch our
videos are gonna be like oh man you
didn't pick me he's a mountain goat fan
not a billy goat fan like mountain goats
are actually goats shut your mouth hey
Hank what are you gonna be for Halloween
I'll answer that I'm going to be a
bumblebee then we're getting the second
bumblebee outfit because the one you
have doesn't fit very well so I might
also be above hey Hank what is your
favorite word in an absolutely
remarkable thing deadpanned I noticed
that you used that exactly once was that
a thing was that a shout out it made me
so happy my favorite word in an
absolutely remarkable thing is beautiful
my Wikipedia page wrongly identifies me
as an actor when it should identify me
as an actor who was literally cut from
the only film he appeared in what is one
thing that should not be pumpkin spice
ginger spice the spice girl what a huge
opportunity they missed to have a
pumpkin spice Hank what would you name a
robot that you found in New York City at
3 o'clock in the morning
Benjamin Benjamin I would name him Karl
because it's an extremely metaphorically
resonant name I've got a forthcoming
video series by the way called how to
read an absolutely remarkable thing
figuratively it's amazing it's gonna be
eight parts 40 minutes and peace spread
out over two months that just got a
raindrop in the I direct I don't know
how did it get through the glasses perv
off Icarus guy Hank what's the best
genre of music to write to i siphon this
the idea that anyone can write while
listening to music is a complete mystery
I mean I would pay $200 right now ticket
don't stop me now out of my house I mean
this is a really good business idea for
anyone out there who wants it uber but
forgetting songs out of my hair what
you've invented is like Hootie and the
Blowfish comes over and it's like well I
guess don't stop me now is gone it's not
actually I just a moment you said don't
stop me now I was like I feel that my
consciousness has been hijacked by an
intelligence outside of myself super
meta wouldn't be the first time Hank
what has been your favorite TV show or
movie of this year oh gosh the movie
that I tend to watch most is taking care
of a two-year-old cuz you can't when do
you have time to watch a movie and the
movie that I watched the most is
Penguins of Madagascar Penguins of
Madagascar is the single most underrated
movie in human history son-in-law Hank
what's been the best part about tour oh
it's hanging out with my brother it is
it is for me too bye